- [Instructor] What we have
here is a visual depiction
of a function.
And this is a depiction
of Y is equal to H of X.
Now when a lot of people see
function notation like this
they see it as somewhat
intimidating until you realize
what it's saying.
All a function is, is
something that takes an input,
in this case it's taking X as
an input and then the function
does something to it and then
it spits out some other value
which is going to be equal to Y.
So for example what is H
of four based on this graph
that you see right over here?
Pause this video and think through that.
Well all H of four means
is when I input four
into my function H what
Y am I spitting out?
Or another way to think about
it, when X is equal to four,
what is Y equal to?
Well when X is equal to four,
my function spits out that Y
is equal to three.
We know that from this
point right over here, so Y
is equal to three, so H
of four is equal to three.
Let's do another example.
What is H of zero?
Pause the video try to work that through.
Well all this is saying is
if I input an X equals zero
into the function what is going
to be the corresponding Y?
Well when X equals zero we
see that Y is equal to four.
So it's as simple as that.
Given the input what is
going to be the output?
And that's what these points
represent, each of these points
represent a different
output for a given input.
Now it's always good to keep
in mind one of the things
that makes it a function is
that for given X that you input
you only get one Y.
For example if we had two dots
here, then all of a sudden
or we have two dots for X
equals six, now all of a sudden
we have a problem
figuring out what H of six
would be equal to because
it could be equal to one
or it could be equal to three.
So if we had this extra dot
here, then this would no longer
be a function.
In order for it to be a
function for any given X,
it has to output a unique
value, it can't output
two possible values.
Now the other way is possible.
It is possible to have two
different X's that output
the same value.
For example, if this was circled
in what would H of negative
four be?
Well H of negative four when
X is equal to negative four,
you put that into our function
it looks like the function
would output two.
So H of negative four
would be equal to two.
But H of two is also equal
to we see very clearly there,
when we input a two into the
function, the corresponding Y
value is two as well.
So it's okay for two
different X values to map
to the same Y value that works.
But if you had some type of
an arrangement, some type
of a relationship where
for a given X value you had
two different Y values,
then that would no longer
be a function.
But the example they gave
us is a function assuming
I don't modify it.